Why do we care about scientists’ Nobel efforts?
Hello everyone, Trace here for DNews.
When someone wins the Nobel prize, everyone
instantly knows they’re kind of a big deal.
Winners not only get a shiny medal but 8 million
Swedish Krona, and of course they're respected and revered.
But it’s far from the only prize recognizing
contributions to the advancement of humanity.
So why is the Nobel prize held in such high
esteem?
Maybe it’s because of the prize’s past.
The Nobel prize has existed for over 100 years
and has been given to some of the most recognizable
names in history, like Albert Einstein -- the
relativity guy, Ivan Pavlov -- the dog guy,
and Werner Heisenberg -- no, not the meth
guy.
It was established by Swedish chemist Alfred
Nobel, who made a considerable fortune off
his invention of dynamite.
In 1895, he secretly drafted his will to set
aside the bulk of his estate for prizes in
5 fields: physics, chemistry, physiology/medicine,
literature, and peace.
Economics was added later by Sweden’s central
bank, though technically it’s not a Nobel
Prize, it’s just named in honor of Alfred
Nobel.
Nobel passed away in 1896 and in 1901, the
first prizes were handed out.
At first, the press was only interested in
the peace and literature awards, as the sciences
were thought to be a bit too niche for the
general public.
But when Marie Curie and her husband were
awarded the 1903 prize in physics, along with
Henri Becquerel, their story captured the
public’s imagination.
The idea of the poor Curie’s scraping by
in a laboratory while they revolutionized
our understanding of atoms made for great
headlines.
They became celebrities, and the scientific
Nobel prizes started getting recognition.
Now the Nobel prize has become a shorthand
for greatness, though the awards are not always
given out controversy free.
Part of the problem is Alfred Nobel stipulated
only 3 people could share the award and the
cash prize that comes with it9.
The cutting edge of science today requires
a lot of collaboration, and sometimes people
who do valuable research are left out.
Other times they’re straight up snubbed,
like Joycelyn Bell Burnell.
She was the first person to observe radio
pulsars, but the 1974 prize in physics was
given to her doctoral thesis advisor.
Talk about a No-Bell prize.
It’s important to remember the winners are
selected by committees and so, of course they’re
fallible.
Their members are appointed by the Royal Swedish
Academy or the medical university Karolinska
Institutet.
Except for the peace prize committee; Alfred
Nobel stipulated that they have to be Norwegian
for... some reason.
Anyway, the committees invite thousands of
people respected in their respective fields
to nominate winners and narrow it down from
there.
When it comes time to announce the winners,
they don’t always make the most perfect or most
obvious picks.
Usually they do select scientists who have
made lasting impacts their field, like Peter
Higgs.
Higgs had to wait almost 50 years for his
prize, because he proposed the Higgs boson’s
existence in 1964, but it wasn’t confirmed
until 2012.
In 2013, the Nobel committee recognized that
he made this massive contribution (pun intended)
to particle physics.
Because of the delay between a scientist's
work and its visible influence, the Nobel
Prize has become something of a career award.
That doesn’t mean nobel laureates are resting
on their laurels and calling it a day once
they’ve won though.
Four scientists have won the nobel prize twice,
including the aforementioned Marie Curie.
She’s not only the first woman to win it,
she remains the only person to win a Nobel
Prize in two different scientific categories.
We can’t do episodes like this without our
sponsors.
If you listen to music and podcasts and are
looking for a new Bluetooth speaker, check
out Monster’s reimagined boombox, the Monster
Blaster.
It’s available for monthly payments starting
at $25.
The Monster Blaster has the power to bring
music to life indoors and out.
Check it out at themonsterblaster.com/dnews.
Higgs’ proposed boson took so long to find
because we had to build the most powerful
atom smasher ever to look for it.
I actually visited; you
can go see that video right here.
Do you
guys keep track of the Nobel prizes?
Do you care?
Are there any that blew your mind?
Let us know in the comments, make sure you
come back every day for more DNews and thanks
for watching!